this is a production of cornell
university
so as the
moira pointed out and the
title says i'm gonna walk you through
how it is to start a breeding program
from scratch with the crop that
many other breeding programs are running
for 100 years or so or even longer
so in okay
in my talk today i'll kind of cover a
shortly background my background
background of the breeding in south
carolina and clemson university then
i'll tell you about the challenges that
i have and accomplishments in this
13-year period
and the accomplishments would kind of be
designated as discovery and application
as what you will learn throughout this
talk is i'm all about application
i don't start discovery unless it's
going to be applied otherwise i don't
see the point of the discovery and so
that's how i uh
structured the talk and basically how i
live my life professionally and mostly
personally too
and so
some of the future things will trickle
through the slides i'm not going to have
a special flight saying future but
you'll get the the gist what the future
is in uh certain points that i cover
okay so that's not what i wanted this is
what i wanted okay so before i start i
always like to start with the slide
showing a great fellow breeder dr oaky
that retired right around the time i got
hired and my first visit was to him and
to dr ralph's corsa and usda and
carnisville west virginia to kind of
pick their minds on how do you start
breeding program for peach from zero
when there are programs in the united
states public and private running for 60
200 years where do i fit what do i do
and dr oaky actually published uh
excellent paper covering the east coast
prunus for stone fruit breeding
breeders and breeding programs and in in
that paper he
listed the breeder qualities and he said
it's just an overall for breedings
doesn't matter if it's a plant or annual
breeding and said that the breeders have
to have a vision uh the ability to see
what's needed and what is feasible that
they have to have a passion and devotion
to job daily and over the years and the
willingness and ability to work for a
distant payoff and you'll see all of
these qualities or maybe lack of them
through my presentation or something
that i need to still work on discipline
you need to keep in mind what is the
goal and execute the many steps that
sometimes seem meaningful
meaningless to get where you want in
efficient way and the final thing is the
risky thing where you actually put your
stuff out there for others to criticize
so uh you'll see some
popping up these words through the
slides to kind of get you an idea
where these disciplines are playing the
part
okay so why peach why in south carolina
south carolina for most of the people
they don't know it because they are
fighting with georgia about the
peach rights
but
here you can see where we are in the
united states
uh we are second in nation for peach
production right behind california for
fresh market beaches
and even though georgia has the rights
to post themselves peach states they are
more like blueberry state lately than
the peach state for the amount of the
production so uh we
have about 18 000 acres or so under the
peaches and it's a number one industry
in our state
so no wonder that
growers wanted the breeding program that
would address the needs of our
environment
so breeding program was rejuvenated in
2008 when i got hired after 25 years of
dormancy
that basically means there was no
crossing going on when i got hired into
the position
so what was
what is that i found out when i got
hired in clemson
so one of the great things about clemson
and luckily we still have that is we
have a great team of people that are all
addressing the same crop from different
points of view we have horticulturalist
pharmacists pathologists entomologists
virologists geneticists but at the time
they did not have active breeder that
actually would pull all this information
and try to deliver genetic solution to
growers needs and so that's where i fit
into the picture
and we still kept all of that team
together which we replaced certain
positions which is really nice that we
did not get rid of them after people
retired
and so we now still are trying to make
uh the best uh possible solution for our
growers so what i found
uh in a clemson with all that great
group of people they had an excellent
germplasm to work with
and
facilities they just did not have the
breeding material going on like crosses
and in different level of selection so
when you
inherit a breeding program you basically
inherit a program where you have all
kinds of stages that you'll see through
my talk of the
level of selection and progression of
the material i did not have that so my
first cross i made in 2008
with peach we wait for three years to
see the fruit so the but sometimes 30
percent of them
can uh uh produce the fruit in the
second year so the first fruit i could
evaluate was in 2010.
so that that was like first two years
which i cherish now and at the time i
was like okay when it's gonna be like
when i'm gonna see my fruit that i could
use to learn about the germplasm without
the problems i come from eastern europe
and where i was assistant professor of
food breeding and genetics and i did
apple and peach breeding but the
problems are not the same
the climate is not the same
so that was a big eye opening something
that we didn't even worry over there is
a big problem here in south carolina
so uh that's what i brought with me i
had a conventional breathing experience
and i was trained to do molecular side
but never had the classes not none of my
education was molecular
which tells you something if you have a
solid genetic knowledge
everything else is like a cookbook or
you have great people that you can
collaborate with which you're gonna see
through my talk that can solve those
issues for you but if you don't know
what you need in your material none of
the great tools that exist right now
that are getting cheaper and cheaper
will get you where you want to be with
your program or development so those are
the the big things that i always try to
kind of instill in my students
to to understand so in 2008 when i
started we had a great community
resource
called genome database for us
peach belongs to the rosaceas crops and
we had an excellent
one-stop shop where you can go and get
idea of what's available markers linkage
maps qtls detected and knowledge at that
time that's all we had most of the
markers were
are uh
rapids rflps which you probably don't
know even what it is or it's like some
ancient history
ssrs which still get used a bit uh and
some of the linkage maps were really uh
low density and
needed
improvements so this is what we have in
2021
the in the in between 2008 and 21 we got
peach genome sequenced and now have many
more other speeches
or sequence genomes we developed some
tools such as slip array and we improve
those tools many more markers linkage
maps
transcriptomic and metabolomic data
available at utls
so
none of that was available when i
started and that's where i
kind of wanted to be in 2008
you know but
you just have to put the work done lucky
for me
most of my uh um
work
coincided with the rosebud project being
funded for two rounds and most of the
things we proposed in that project was
what i was hired to do so and
so
when i got hired the first thing was to
go and talk to growers okay so what what
is it that you want what is the ideal
pitch that i need to create for you that
you don't have right now available for
you because if you look into the
patenting release there are about 500
peaches available for growers to pick to
grow
the problem is when you grow them in
south carolina you encounter some
problems so what they wanted me to do is
the standard yellow flesh
firm
melting freestone with blush fifty
percent of higher they wanted the
soluble solids to be at least nine
bricks or higher in early material which
always doesn't taste really well
then reduce the split pitting in the
early material and extend the ripening
season if i can and fix the size of the
fruit in early ripening material
and of course
introduce the resistance to the diseases
that was the that was the niche where my
program fit
where other programs not that they
didn't want to work on it they did not
have environment to see those problems
on their material so when we would bring
the peaches from california to south
carolina they would fail miserably
because they were susceptible the
humidity brought some so many disease
and insect pressure issues that they've
never seen in california with the dry
climate that they have and so that's
where i fit and so in between in the
meantime
i basically figure out that i need to
also work on
restricting the chilling requirement
because of the changes in the climate
when i was hired or was interviewing for
the position in 2007 there were no
peaches in southeast
there was late spring frost wiped out
the whole production
so then also i wanted to extend the life
of fruit on the tree to reduce the
number of harvests for growers and to
increase the quality of the fruit
because the fruit unfortunately that you
buy in the store is not even close to
what you get when you pick it from the
tree so we want to kind of close that
gap and also nutritional quality and
flavor were some of the things on my
mind and many others that you'll see
trickling that i'm not going to even
mention
so
based on that the the goal initial goals
of the program were of course develop a
high quality productive disease
resistant peaches for southeast
environment
and of course the main focus was
combining all that great quality with
the disease resistance and two diseases
that we kind of focused on the bacterial
spot and brown rot that are actually
creating a big problems for our growers
in the meantime as i already mentioned i
kind of expanded that portfolio and try
to pull all other traits in because
you'll understand later when i go
through the how many years it takes to
to develop anything and create any
variability in your material that you
need to kind of be a
magician and visionary and see 20 years
from now what growers would need because
when they come and ask you it's now they
want it tomorrow and you know that
that's not working that way and as moira
mentioned i kind of got dragged
into the
rootstock breeding as well
and
i'm on that side just as a breeder i
make crosses i do genetics but i leave
the rootstock evaluation to the experts
because that's now becoming a big
problem
uh if you you know that uh trees uh
compound
uh
from rootstock so roots are from
different plants than the scion the
above ground part so if the rootstock is
not fitting and cannot survive on a
certain soil no matter how good your
scion is there is no production and so
that's how i kind of ended up
leading the project we might say it's a
funny story but you go where the need is
again what the growers need so here is
just uh
to go through some challenges i already
mentioned the climate consumer demands
we as a consumer we flip one year to
another what we want or how we want it
uh lower pesticide input better
nutritional quality and so you you kind
of have to predict that also the
producer needs they consistent
sustainable production cost-effective
disease resistance and
one that i found out is the hardest one
is the retail education
because we in the meantime got so many
different types of peaches that nobody
pays attention to nobody educates how
you should sell them how you should tell
the consumers okay this is different
from what you used to in apple you name
the apple cultivars that doesn't happen
in peach you don't go into the store to
buy granny smith or cosmic or snapdragon
or what whatever name you know you like
you get a big basket with a mixture of
peaches peaches last only two weeks so
you have mixture of several cultivars
our growers grow
uh in a round of 40 to 60 different
cultivars throughout the season to cover
the whole season so
there there's work to be done there
this is kind of the bird view of what my
program is doing or trying to do and
some of the things i'll touch today and
many of those will kind of be left over
uh and so i just wanted you just to have
an idea how many things played a part in
uh just creating one tree that has all
these characteristics that we want to
combine
this is where the magic happens
this is our farm and you can see that
the locations is ideal for the fruit
growing it's surrounded by the lake
and so
with uh arrows you're gonna see later on
which where i have my fields we
basically have three sections that are
already cleared section here
here that goes into this and here is the
main building with the labs and the
section that's here all of this land
here and here also belongs to the farm
we just did not clear the woody area
for it to be used it's a and you can see
it's about 200 acres of land
and 90 percent of that is under the
beach and the rest is under the
different fruits for mainly student
education and pleasure for us to eat
different fruits whatever we can grow
and so
i'm one of the biggest user on the land
because i plant my hybrids i keep them
there for two fruit in years and then
after that
i graft them move them to another
location within the farm where they are
trained and kept similar to what the
growers do in the
regular production and then i look at
them for two three more fruiting years
there then we do another selection and
then we move them into so-called
replicated trials so these errors kind
of showing you where i had at the time
because this this drone picture is no
longer accurate you know
things are moving on a yearly basis
where my things were at the farm
and so like here is the isolated one
where we try to grow without fungicides
to see if the brown raw tolerance that
we
developed into the material is actually
holding up and how much we can actually
reduce the spray will we will never be
able to eliminate the spraying because
uh
it's just the type of the fungus that
will always be there but if we can
reduce the number of sprays to maybe
just before harvest and not the whole
season that's going to be a big winner
on the side for growers and the
consumers
so
i kind of alluded to the challenge of
the time so this is the timeline of the
breeding program in the year one we
pollinate then we stratify the seed
because they need a cold uh treatment
before they're gonna germinate we plant
them in the greenhouse when they
overwinter if the material is the mother
tree is the early ripening at the time
of harvesting the fruit embryo is
immature so you have to put them in
tissue culture to
give them the nutrients keep them under
the four degrees celsius to give them
the cold treatment and then raise the
seedlings and then plant them in the
greenhouse they overwinter in greenhouse
and the next year springtime we plant
them in the field they grow there for
two years and then we start evaluating
the fruit
and so
here is uh some of the numbers that i've
been accumulating throughout these years
and this is where i am right now i'm in
the replicated trial stage where you can
see starting from all of these numbers
here where it is about 1.7
of the evaluated trees
end up to the second level of selection
and then out of these we select those
that go into the replicated trials now
right now i have 10 advanced selections
in replicated trials that are at seven
locations throughout the southeast
and they uh last
this summer we had a second year of data
collected from those and some of them
with the
research stations with the universities
some of them are with growers and out of
all of these one stood out for the
growers that they really like and that's
going to be my first release cultivar so
yeah i came came to the finish line in
year 13 i mean it's not released yet we
we are collecting the data because it
takes time for everything you learn uh
through the talk but uh that that's so
fulfilling to know that all that
planning and work actually resulted in
some excellent cultivar that's bacterial
spot resistance which is which is the
big big deal for us
okay so how do we do phenotyping or
selection in our program we do it uh in
a field basically walk the field and eat
the peaches all day long
and
and then uh jogged some data in it
you'll see i'll mention some of the uh
gadgets that i've been trying to test
through my
life as a breeder here uh to go to
something that's much more manageable
and then we bring the fruit to the lab
and we run the lab tests to determine
different qualities and then try to
merge all of that data into one to help
us decide which ones are worth moving to
the next level of selection where we
invest the money into grafting them on
the rootstock training them as the trees
in the regular production and which of
course cost money across the labor
what i was hired to do is to merge the
conventional breeding
be the molecular tools
to
speed up the selection and be more
efficient in selecting so those are the
two different things you want to
eliminate material that has no chance of
having the combination of traits you
want early on so you don't waste the
time and resources in evaluating and you
can go and follow the the slide i'm not
gonna read uh the final idea was to
increase the efficiency and
that's something which this cartoon here
in the top right shows that we try to do
with the first rosebud project just look
at the fruit quality uh define what is
the
heat quality fruit quality trade that
growers are after try to develop the
markers to try to at least predict which
parent combinations we should use to get
that quality
because more so than often than not when
you combine two great looking parents
the children are not not anything close
to the parents it's always the second
generation or the third even in the
human population they're always saying
to my mom why am i like this
i mean you you you look so great when
you're a young girl and then my daughter
is like my mom you know so it's keep
generation
so it happens with the plans guys too
nothing nothing is different there too
sometimes the great parents are just
disappointing
and so you you have to kind of know more
under the surface what's going on
so what we try to do
uh when i started there were great uh
level of maps
and
known locations of the traits and genes
but not many tests not even one
and to get from that knowing where your
genie is responsible for certain trait
to the tool or test that you can apply
and trust
believe me we breeders are rare breed
you don't trust slightly because it
takes a hard work to get that seedling
and so you need to really trust that
test or information you're getting to
kind of chop that tree and remove it
because once it's gone that's it
and so here is some of the tools that we
were using in phenotyping and the
countless number of trays and when we
did to develop
five or six tests for fruit quality
within rose breed one then under the
rose breed two we said okay now we have
some tools for the fruit quality but we
really need the disease resistance so i
kind of doubled down in the first rose
breed using the tools that we developed
for uniform genotyping phenotyping to
already start working on the bacterial
spot and here is the picture of my phd
student at the time
he basically found out that there are
two genes and on two regions in the
peach genome that are responsible for
tolerance or susceptibility to bacterial
spot in fruit because you can see here
on these pictures what does bacterial
spot do to the fruit
it's not bad fruit to eat but nobody's
gonna buy it or nobody's gonna reach for
that fruit to eat it also can defoliate
the tree like here
and that happens in july so trees are
basically wasting all of the energy that
they need for the next year flowering to
push another round of leaves because
they basically get defoliated in the
middle of the season so the growers told
me we don't care how the tree looks as
long as it doesn't affect the next year
production
we want to clean fruit so that was my
kind of first focus on and so we
developed the ssr based test wasn't
perfect but at least it allowed me to
select the right parents and select some
level of selection for the
hybrids in 2010 after two years of
crossing when i got mediocre like
thousand fifteen hundred seedlings i
said okay that's it anybody who's
willing to go out in march
let's go emasculate and i ended up with
the 15 000 seedlings
well never again
because two years after what i did i was
just walking down the roads and eating
peaches and by the time i got to the end
there's a time to start all over again
because they don't ripe at the same time
and so i said okay no i'm not gonna do
that until i have the marker to
eliminate something that's susceptible
for the bacterial spot i won't be able
to cut the numbers because everything
else fruit quality wise it can go here
and there but for me
make it or break it is bacterial spot
tolerance if it doesn't have it i just
don't care what any other traits it has
at the greenhouse stage so in the
meantime we perfected the test
and now we have a snip based test with
the cusp
application we run it on an endpoint pcr
machine those that do this will
understand what i'm talking about we
don't need a real time point
machines we just needed to read the
plate
we use the crude dna extraction so the
price is really low like 10 cents per
per plant
and and that's the test developed by
strawberry group so you are hinting to
the family and borrowing from other and
culinary symphony and what's going on in
the rosate later on but that's the
beauty of it you look into within the
family that your plant species belongs
to and you can pick many things and
tools and ideas from others and you
don't have to reinvent the wheel so we
were really lucky that that test
actually
proved to be excellent the university of
florida group developed a test for there
it works with the high resolution
melting with ssr with the snip
genotyping and it's a crude extract
that's just the beauty of it and it
takes just the two
homemade
buffers that you have the chemicals
lying around in your lab to make it in
one day and it's just two steps by
betting over 19 in the plus four so it's
really really
easy and worth trying for for all of the
students and colleagues that are
listening i urge you if you have an
issue with pricey extraction and if it's
just for the quick marker test try that
test it's really a new i mean while i
was bragging about that test you could
ever
read all of the
uh numbers in the meantime we are right
now
testing um over six thousand five
thousand two hundred and thirty
seedlings were
stratified up and one more thing that i
wanted to point out what we do even now
to shorten the uh period of the dorm or
the
uh youth
uh we apply the hormones to break the
dormancy
so basically the 5 000 seedlings that we
already tested are growing now and will
be planted at the farm our climate
allows me to plant them in the same year
we actually made across so they over
winter at our farm and next year so i
shaved the one year from those three
years before i see fruit uh in actually
making the decision on which fruit uh
hybrids are going to be
advanced to the next level so i was very
pleased to find out when we
um
developed the ssr test and later on the
slip test to go back through my program
for anything that i selected based on
the
phenotype just the quality of the fruit
that i already have some great series of
material that covers the ripening season
that's whatever i listed there as a
ideal peach
and so which meant
uh my great colleague john clark said uh
it's serendipity you never know what
you're gonna get so you have have to
kind of have that in mind not just trust
you know tools or so i'm i'm kind of in
between you know i'm developing the
tools i trust them a bit but not
completely i still kind of
sneak something as long as i have a
space i'll probably keep more than when
i need to but that's that's just like my
children i cannot just you know get them
out because once they're out that's it
so that's the easy story
my students would not say so easy for
the bacterials
well now we get into the fungal disease
brown rot and that one is the nasty one
because it starts with the flowering and
it goes into the fruiting so the whole
season growers have to spray
and then even goes into the post harvest
because if you have one
fruit that's diseased in the storage
it's going to ruin a whole
basket or whatever crate they have with
the peaches
so we
did classical you know phenotyping and
then we developed some families and then
you can see here like the average for
the family is nothing exciting about but
within the family we had some that were
completely clean and so the solid
bar color means wounded means the flesh
tolerance and
striped ones mean the skin tolerance so
we would
wound the fruit to allow the entry point
for the fungus and to see how flesh
tolerates
infection and also
try to have the fruit with the perfect
skin without the micro
cracks to make it hard for fungus to
penetrate to see how well they're going
to tolerate
and some of these actually end up being
with the right
uh type of flesh
and with the right level of the blush
the
the problem that we had is that the
source of the tolerance comes from the
land race from brazil
well that thing looks more like this but
no redness
it's clingstone which means that the
flesh is clinging to the pit which is
what people don't want they want to like
split and toss the pit and eat the flesh
and then it's also non-melting so it has
kind of a rubbery feel when you bite
into it and those are perfectly fine
peaches they're just different and
different from what people are used to
especially for this region in north
america they're more uh accustomed to
the
melting type of flesh that basically
falls apart in your mouth and foolish
juicy and so that's kind of a
educational side that we need to do well
when we did the genetics on this
it's not a clean story but like for the
fruit for bacterial spot we had signals
all over the genome
and we could not get a clear picture so
there was no way for us to develop some
ssr or snip based tests to run
and then uh we
use genomic prediction to see if we can
pick up the best
[Music]
material to move forward and overlay
that with the bacterial spot fruit to
kind of go in parallel for both diseases
so since last year micros are designed
based on the boat information so i put
the point in making the parents the best
possible chance to create that
combination that i need and you probably
heard if anybody before talked about
breeding it's a number game
so the more cross the more progeny you
can get the better the chance you have
to get that combination of trades that
you're going after
so
i'll just cover this really briefly we
also look into nutritional composition
if you heard of people talking about php
which is genetically really really
uniform and you don't see much variation
on the genome level
well on phenotyping phenotypic level
when you look at them and taste them
there's a bunch of variation and we
still have a work to do to figure out
what is it that gives that variability
so we found a great variation in
nutritional compounds accumulation and
we did some mapping we tried to do the
genome-wide association because of the
white panel and some uh by parental
mapping we also looked in the specific
ones into carotenoids
and also across the whole prunus family
family of stone fruits in this case
apricot plum and peach we wanted to see
what is it
actually we know that the flavor and
aroma you get in a white flesh peach is
due to carotenoids that are not spent
in giving yellow flesh color to the
yellow fresh peaches and it's all due to
one gene
and so if that gene functions you end up
with the yellow if it doesn't you end up
with the white
because the carotenoids don't get
processed
and so we wanted to to find out okay
what is the variability of carotenoids
in the yellow flesh material then
compare it to the plum in apricot to see
if is the same or different
and then did some aroma profiles or
extremes to see can we pick some aromas
to actually bring that great aroma white
flesh peach has into the yellow flesh
and so it's still work going on but
there were some really funny and
interesting things that we found because
we analyzed 300 peaches in two seasons
in really expensive and labor's
profiling on carotenoids and we got
completely different results than what
was published for years because
everybody was doing two or three
cultivars because it's so expensive and
so labor-intensive so we are really
looking forward to see what's going to
trickle out down the pipeline from this
work
so
looking into all of this you can see
that many traits get mapped and many of
them actually land on the same
chromosomes and in the same regions so
we call those so-called hotspots and so
what what our idea is to define these
blocks that are not
recombining that always are inherited
together and then understand variation
of each for this block how many
different variations it has and what
does it mean phenotypically to basically
do this is for chromosome 4 cartoon that
we figured out has 14
blocks then do not recombine and then do
the design approach to cherry pick for
each of these different blocks which one
we want in the ideal page of course
easier said than done but
since
uh i started my position almost every
single crop in the prunus genus
economically important crop has a genome
sequence the only one that doesn't is
the tarte cherry because they're you
know polyploid so we kind of put them
aside because they're hard to work with
so we i'm happy and lucky that peaches
deployed self-pollinating you know
have all kinds of
nice nice features to work with so those
three years of waiting for the fruit
doesn't seem that bad when you look in
some other
fruit crops that are longer so when with
these uh genome sequence now we have
ability of actually comparing the
regions in different genomes and seeing
if the same traits are landing in the
same chromosomes and then if they do
maybe that means that the trades that
are mapped in one crop but not in the
other will actually point to you in the
region in the genome for this other crop
so you don't have to do all the by
parental mapping all of this leg work to
get to the point where you can just
compare them and get an idea okay do i
have
uh variability do i have more genes in
this region and so this is what we've
tried to do between sweet cherry and
peach because within the region on
chromosome 4 from 7 to 20 million base
pairs we have mapped the same fruit
quality
traits and so peach has many more traits
mapped in this region than cherry so we
could kind of go back and extrapolate
cherry has one big one that we don't
which is the fruit size so you know we
can kind of uh
use the family and resemblance between
genomes which we call culinarity and
synteny which is even on the level of
rosacea species very high to kinda
inform ourselves in what is the
possibility because as a breeder you
need to know are you in a bottleneck
is there nothing you can do to break
that solid block that gets inherited and
carries the bad trades that you don't
want you need to know that so then you
don't waste your time and you try other
approaches to kind of do the
recombination so one of the things that
we used you know if you work with the
model species
there's all kinds of mutations and stuff
that people accumulate arabidopsis is
one of the great example that you can
find all kinds of answers we don't have
that that much in the true trees but
there is one great mutation family in
japanese plum so all of these listed
here are the five sport of the same
cultivars and they were picked up
because they ripened in a different time
so in the fruit trees with apple being
one of the lead in uh is you can just
walk through the orchard and you can see
the branch having more red fruit bigger
fruit earlier ripening fruit you just
scan that branch you vegetatively
propagate it and there go your there's a
new cultivar so many apple cultivars
were actually named like that so we have
the same similar situation in uh
japanese plum
and what
was not known at the time is that not
only they ripen at the different times
they also have a different way of
ripening so peach fruit is climacteric
which means you pick it from the tree
and it continues to soften and right
but there is a non-climatic or uh
suppressed climacteric type that we
found here and basically when you apply
uh external ethylene which is what they
do with apple to basically keep them in
storage and then apply that external
ethylene and then ripen it for
selling it in the store
with this plum b encounter uh that there
are some
that do not soften
ever to the right rate of softening of
the regular or the original cultivar so
we were looking at the genomes and
transcriptomes of those and trying to
understand if we can kind of apply that
to peach
because peach flesh can be
softening fast softening non-softening
stony heart
sony harming even if you add external
ethylene it's never going to soften and
so there are some issues with the maybe
making them transportable more
tolerant to processing in the packing
lines and all of these things that we
are trying to look into that
you can imagine how many data i collect
all the genotyping phenotyping profiling
all of this with different students
different colleagues that i collaborate
so breeders are great
uh how do i say in the like
people that assembly group people or
like people around themselves or
expertise around themselves i cannot
know everything so i'm a great person to
notify know who knows and who i can
actually collaborate with to help me one
of these guys is dr sasky which is a
great uh um
translational genomics and uh poor guy
works office next to mine so it's like
i'm always there asking for something
because i'm like hands-on i like to do
it on my own because if you work with
the people that are bioinformatics only
these sometimes do not talk the same
language more often than not and so we
are getting better but if you understand
how they think
it helps a great deal of actually making
faster improvements to whatever you want
to accomplish when when you want to use
uh some tools and so i already mentioned
the genome database for exactly and
they're basically helping me by
developing
databases where i can store all of that
data sets then something that was
developed for a beat breeding program
i actually utilize in mind it's called
field book app that i go into the field
collect the data and it gets into the
breeding information management system
with beam cs4
stands for and then it's immediately at
my fingertips to make a decision even on
a daily basis as soon as i collected
something in the field
so in 2010 when i first looked into my
trees and i was waiting for them to
first time have the fruit it was a
wishful thinking now it became the
reality now i know
many things about those trees before
they ever see the fruit which actually
cuts down
enormously the waste of uh effort that i
was putting in into trees that i would
just knock out and never never do
anything no at once
of course i was so pleased to see that
uh among the 2014 crosses i actually
have a brown rock tolerant material that
is free stone melting yellow flesh
almost hundred percent redness on the
skin and i also have a bacterial spot
resistant material similar fruit quality
and one with both of them in the same
it still needs improvement on the fruit
size but you know the hard part is there
i already have two tolerances in that
material and growers are interested in
trying to grow them for the organic type
of a production so something that i
actually did not think about you know
the vision part you know i was like okay
no that's not for me you'll never be
able to grow organically fruit but then
just might
of course
reading program at university externally
funded so that's all the brands and
stuff
major ones that were supporting the work
and of course the
south carolina peach council and
department of agriculture
and many many many people
not just faculty that supported me and
helped me but students starting from
undergraduate and graduates that were
working on all of these nice things that
i'm standing here and showing off for
that has an army of people behind me
that helps with actually achieving
this
so that's what i had i hope i didn't go
much over the time and i'm open for any
questions you might have
do you have any questions for cassini
and
it seems to be focused on just the
science but we know the quality this is
resistance a lot of confirmed by
stocks so do you have any plans more
towards the sort of breeding
stock
that's a great questions one that i
would quickly answer i don't care
if you're the rootstock breeder you need
to make a rootstock that does not ruin
my science
so that's the funny answer to the
question but
and it's a reality it takes 15 to 20
years to develop the scion
up to 40 to develop the root stock
so
not really a good for the rootstock
breeders because not that only that they
have to have all the traits in the
rootstock then they have to test on the
major cultivars to see what effects that
rootstock does and that make sure that
it's not detrimental because if you
think of it once you produce the orchard
if you have the winner rootstock you're
done because everything is going to be
planted on it but then if five years
into the planting the orchard there is a
major flaw that like causes all of the
trees to die or something you basically
run somebody out of the business
so that that's why
rootstock breeding is much harder
because they have that additional level
of testings so now that i was dragged
into the rootstock breathing you know
now i'm paying attention you know
because now we want to develop the
rootstock that is
um
tolerant to the replant diseases there
is a bunch of things that affect them
when you replant them and
if you think of it in south carolina we
do not have a new land
we are planting over and over in the
same land and so our milaria project
that moira mentioned that got just
funded uh it's a
crucial problem for peaches in southeast
for cherries in michigan it's slowly
creeping up in california as well for
grapes for bone anything that's long
live armillaria is a really interesting
fungus that it doesn't there's like more
than 30 different species of armillaria
they adjusted to every plant under
because it lives in the soil and it's
major under the uh uh forests in like
colorado oregon area and they learn to
live together we need to find out how so
we make them live together if we cannot
get rid of it yeah but that's that's an
excellent question and that that's uh
uh
we never actually asked
is there something in the scion you know
towards the rootstock we always look
okay that rootstock you know delays the
bloom or you know makes it earlier so
they get uh you know killed by the frost
in the spring but sometimes maybe there
is a backtalk from the scion that
we just don't look at
i have a follow-up question for that so
do you think that
given the age of genomics and now that
you have all of these you know having a
pan genome basically if rootstock
breeding can actually kind of follow
and have shorter cycles of selection
given that you have more genetic
information now actually we are hoping
to achieve that because uh it's like
opportunistic mostly now that the the
pricing is not that high and that we
learn that we have the genomes we
compare them that there's so much
similarity now many so-called orphan
crops are getting picked up and much
faster to the level of these first ones
that started like peach was chosen as a
representative because it was deployed
you know we had a
dihydroid individual to sequence the
genome so all of the things were working
forward but now uh
cherries we have several genome sequence
for cherries now in the rootstock we are
doing the same sequencing genomes doing
the comparison trying to find the
markers and then understand because most
of the things for roots talk are
happening under the soil
you know like the and uh
one other thing that i didn't even
mention is the just a root root uh uh
environment you know uh micarisa what's
going on there i mean we did not even
touch that there's a whole line of uh
colleagues that are working on it that
we
simply have no way of bringing together
because it's so expensive and all of the
funding that we are looking for which
as a president of nipb and trying to
change and to raise awareness what the
breeders need
uh that we need to kind of open up the
bigger lines of funding something like
nsf has but for application type work
because really when you see how many
problems we have you need the whole
picture not just focus on one line and
then ignoring what's going on the on the
other uh
research that can actually
solve your problem
and i think there is there are questions
in the chat in questions
so let's go back
oh why don't i have a test site in
georgia
great question mark
because uh our main growing region is so
close to georgia border and the climate
is almost exactly the same and what's
left of the
georgia peaches is left on the their
northern border next to south carolina
that's why there is really no reason
for me to plant the trees there because
the environment and everything i need to
see
they georgia growers can see in south
carolina yeah
great question
okay so yellow peaches often have a more
tart taste than white peaches do you
know which gene determines peach fruit
acidity are yellow flesh and fruit
acidity highly linked in peach
we do
have the gene for acidity in peach and
no they are not
linked we have both white and yellow
flesh peaches with low acids with medium
or high acids and
the third days that just depends on what
uh
that's uh what you have in the market
so that's what people
expect
so that that's one of the thing when
you're breathing and you want to change
uh the people's perception when you when
you were kid and you bite into peach you
want that memory from when you were kid
and then suddenly that's not it what is
it you know what what am i eating and so
that's the thing there are yellow
peaches that are not not dark that are
excellent and so
for me personally i don't like lost
peaches i just cannot i don't like the
peach where i have to go and drink water
after i bite into it and there are some
of these that are like pure sugar and i
don't i like the hint of acidity just
enough to keep me from actually
going after water after i bite into the
beach
excellent question
okay based on your experiences and
lesson learned do you have any
suggestions for the young readers who
are just starting their careers
oh many how much time do i have
so um
what i can tell you be open
and uh accept to be criticized
i always look at the criticism as a
great lessons learned and i don't never
uh
never get it personally
because there are so many things that uh
breeders know and accumulate that never
is going to get
it never going to get published this is
not something that you publish that's
something that you learn and then you
just apply and so the first thing i did
is just reach out breeders are excellent
community i know we get with the pis uh
like protection intellectual protections
and stuff and exchange of materials we
found a way around it we do mtas we do
certain things but we are still a great
group that collaborates and because it's
such a long period of time we are so
happy that somebody young gets the
position and so when i got the position
everybody was so excited in the in the
peach world because they were finally
great because at the time
north carolina breeding program stopped
breeding
uh usda byron
dr oaky was about retirement
doctor scorsese in carnesville was few
years shy of retirement he retired now
they i don't have uh
information that they replace the
breeding they don't even replace like
they had a several breeders through
course of the years retire and
we did not replace them with the
breeders
so it's it's really a great community
and you just if it's
the program like mine
where you
are
kind of jumping in the pool with big
sharks so to speak private and public
you have to find a way to earn your spot
so you find something that nobody wants
to work on because the low hanging fruit
is already being taken care of you know
and so now the harder things are left
and you have to kind of pick your poison
you know and try to work with the with
the group and with the system that was
given to you
yes
so there's one quality attribute that's
super important to my wife which is the
fuzziness
of peach and she does not like super
fuzzy peaches
she would always prefer nectarine look
at me i'm just i don't know if people
can see me but uh you can say fuzzy then
i can always feel them in my face
because some people get a little bit of
allergic reactions but so what do we
know about um because you didn't mention
fuzziness as one of your phenotypic
traits or
how important is it is fuzziness in your
breeding program
and are you know the nectarines come
into play at all and do you ever see
spontaneous mutations towards nectarines
that's a perfect question
because then you know when you get hired
you may have to repeat the question i'm
not sure
okay so the question was about the
fuzziness is that something that i look
into my breathing program how important
it is
and
and i said that it's a great question
because
when i got hired into position it was
peach yellow flesh melting you know
but then
you have to be tenured you have to get
your position so you do what you hire to
but you always can side track and do
some other fun things
so i have nectarines the problem with
the climate where i'm breeding is that
nectarines don't do well because of all
the humidity humidity fuzziness people
don't like but that protects speech from
many issues of insects and
the
diseases
and
the the for the
um my brain stopped working how the
growers process speeches after the
harvest they get rid of the fats
so
it's not as important but that question
is actually excellent because uh
recently i had a talk with somebody and
they were asking about that and said
that they've noticed and i noticed in my
program that they're getting less and
less fuzzy
nobody actually work because it requires
a special equipment you have to look
into the thickness of the fuzz of each
of the it's like a hair on your face you
know some more hairy the other ones are
less
same with the peach
and
i have the one that growers like uh
called sc1 right now we still are
looking for the name
that one has almost no fuzz
so i have a fast scale from zero which
is nectarine to nine
and about seven you just don't want to
touch that no not even bring it
next to your face
and and there are many more that are one
i mean you would think that it's a
nectarine and you know it's not because
you know nectar is shiny and it's it's
such a
fine fine fuzz that you don't mind
biting into that one but because of the
way the peaches are processed and
displayed in the stores you could not
recognize what's the nectarine what's
the pitch once they're done uh with it
uh on the uh in the packing packing line
is what i was looking for yeah
okay let me see what the next
as you implement market assisted
selection for more and more trades it
drives up the need for larger ceiling
yes
populations so now as you being to begin
to implement genomic selection for more
quantitative traits will you need to
further increase population size and do
you have the capacity to multiple trades
with genomic selection finally okay
uh looking forward to seeing me there
okay so yeah that that's an excellent
question so what i've seen now that for
three years i'm using the markers
bacterial spot
very soon i'm not going to be using it
because i'm using the parents that are
homozygous for the two locations so
everything is homozygous for certain
cross i don't do the markers so now i'm
kind of moving to another traits and
then the the size of the population as i
said we would want to have the largest
that we have but
think of this
peach fruit is just one seed so i make a
cross it's a one seed one plant
we
emasculate pollinate about two to three
thousand flowers on the tree we're
extremely happy if we get 200
plants out of it so it's really hard in
the process there's so many levels where
they don't germinate germinate die
your something happens so it's really
really hard so what i'm trying more to
focus with the genomic selection is kind
of look into the parental selection to
be honest more and then as i get crafty
and find out how i'm gonna fund this i
might actually move into
doing it on my seedlings later on but
right now material spot is my main one
and then we are right now testing the uh
chill requirement marker because i want
to constrain them between the six to
seven hundred uh chill hours and what
i'm working also researching the heat
requirement i want to raise the heat
requirement so they'll sit there get
their chill requirements satisfied and
they won't bloom until they get their
heat that's our problem right now that
we kind of have to have both control
your child where you want it but have
the heat really high so they don't bloom
until you actually want them to blow
okay and that was the last question on
the chat
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu